hello everybody I hope that you are good
I want to talk really quickly about what
we saw yesterday in the fomc meeting
okay because there is not that much to
say really
um but the thing is that the FMC
statement was you know only repeating
that the two percent inflation Target
Remains the Same that they are not
thinking about changing it
um that they're gonna still be the
dependent to to make decisions for the
next interest rates
um then the press conference was quite
boring because you don't Powell was
going around in circles and he was not
really answering the questions and the
journalists have to repeat all those
questions several times to try to get an
answer
um but anyway I think then at the end of
the press conference he started to sleep
a bit and he gave some more answers well
I remember that the first words that he
said in the press conference uh well in
the in the statement when he came out on
his and he spoke he said that the bank
system is
solid is sound and resilient which it's
you know those words were very similar
to the President Biden said uh this week
um
I don't know guys I don't know how you
feel about one they're telling me
so many times trying to convince me that
something is okay I tend to think that
it's not okay and now if you check Park
West Bank
it's not doing right to be honest so I
don't know if that's true then at the
end also he said
that he thinks that this time is
different and that he thinks he's more
likely to avoid a refreshing than to
enter a recession
um I don't know basically say that this
time is different we'll see about it I
don't believe that the bank said the
same back in 2008.
uh so it's difficult to believe that
um what else uh well basically he said
other data dependent and that he didn't
say that they are going to pause the the
increasing of the rates now but he said
that they are obviously closer to the
end of all a cycle
um I think they're most likely the most
likely thing is that they pause here
that's why that's why everybody is
expecting he also wanted to attack the
federal bonds Futures Market as we
anticipated because they are pricing in
three rate Cuts this year of 25 basis
Points each so it was quite clear that
he was gonna come out and say the Verona
could rate this year okay he said that
back in in March 22nd so that's pretty
much what happened and there was not
that much volatility it seems that the
volatility started coming now look at
this look at that candle okay and I'll
tell you my my view for the market right
now I think what we saw here
okay in this Zone it's something very
similar to what we saw in this area you
can see many weeks to the upside above
well below resistance in this case was
the 50 EMA for our time frame then they
rejected price here something very
similar happened a lot to fix to the
upset but price didn't break up this
Zone
that was the liquidity pool and now it's
fallen again to test the 50 EMA in the
four hour time frame now what I think
that is going on here I don't know if
I'm if I'm right I might be wrong but I
don't see anything really bearish
okay what I'm anticipating really here
is either to see you know this is a push
up
retwisted as a 50ma
in for our time frame and then
continuation maybe to the next liquidity
pool but you have to be cautious because
then yes this is a an imbalance too okay
so maybe they come all the way here or
they do some kind of uh I would say like
a force with like a trap they come below
the 50ma and then they come back above
it really quickly in the next candle and
they go to the next liquidity pool so
for now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
wait and see how this Scandal closes
that's gonna close in 20 minutes and how
the next one goes but if this one closes
above the 50ma or if this one closes
below the 50ma per week so the next one
close in above it okay then I would
consider that that was a false move and
we are okay for continuation to the
upside to the next liquidity pool
okay so that's pretty much everything
that I have in in my head I know how
many Traders are going to start drawing
this kind of uh uh you know uptrends and
I have to say that if price comes
uh to this Zone you know the most likely
thing is that there is a lot of Traders
place in their their long Sia maybe it
works again okay but at some point this
trend like the most likely thing is that
it breaks down
okay
um usually I'll tell you I'm trying to
figure out more about how the market
maker plays this kind of
um Trends but usually what they do is
like you know they are expecting price
up they come back it they spice up they
Spike up they come back to it again and
then in one of these what they do is
like they do a very nasty Spike up
something like this and then they break
it they break below okay excuse me for
all I mean I should have used the the
straight lines
um Let me let me remove that so
something like this okay we could see if
if the 50ma gets invalidated and they
come to the trend line and then we see
some kind of support usually what I see
that the market maker does is right
before breaking this trend line they
usually like to spike up quite a lot
more compared to the previous times and
then they have a very sharp dump to
break below because many Traders are
gonna say okay if this holds
two what three times why not fourth time
so they're gonna place the lungs here
and then boom they're gonna get chopped
okay so keep an eye on that but for now
I'm more gonna look for is going to be
to to hold support in the 50 I mean the
forward time frame I mean it would see
some kind of push up retrace
continuation to the next liquidity pool
okay now let's have a look at the
liquidation heat Maps let's see if they
back up this thought or if you have to
maybe consider again a new projection
I'm here in hablo Capital let's start
with a 12 hours time frame okay to get
some context
um okay I see that they've just hit
these liquidations there are some more
at twenty thousand six hundred
um maybe they come here first and maybe
we get that little fake move below the
50ma let's see what happens but you can
see that 29
525 there is quite a lot of liquidations
and this Zone matches with the liquidity
pool we were talking about then next the
seven days time frame let's have a look
okay it's just loaded okay this is
getting very interesting
because we can see that there is a lot
of liquidity again between 29 500 and 29
uh six hundred okay that's again the
liquidity pool so on so why not what am
I see this song getting hit okay we only
need that 50 AMA in the four hour time
frame to hold also you can see quality
of liquidity at 30 300 that matches with
uh about Above This previous High all
right one month time frame I'm expecting
to see quite a lot of liquidity to the
upside
correct let me check this
wow this is really interesting because
you can see that below the previous lows
at 26 400 there is a lot of liquidity
but it's quite clear that there is quite
a lot more liquidity to the upside you
know in the shorter term this is one
month time frame only so 33
300 30 800 and then of course again
above the previous highs because the
previous y the previous high was 31 100
and a very Squad of liquidity at 31 300.
um okay and if we go to the three months
time frame let's see what we see
um now you can see that it's getting
more divided in this Zone because the
liquidity
at 22
500 this is still there it's brutal
um also again in the twenty five
thousand four hundred six hundred
this makes sense because this area it's
uh um it was a very strong previous
resistance that it hasn't been tested as
support yet so it's a sort of interest
in the chart and then to the upside I
see quite a lot of liquidity to be
honest at 31 300
um even higher at 33 400.
um I'm gonna say that I'm not gonna
favor
well I look let's let's let's let's put
it like this okay
If We Hold
above the four hour 50 EMA okay what
when I we're gonna favor higher prices
I'm gonna favor even 30k 30k is on the
table as long as the 4 Hour 50ma holds
or even 31 why not 31k why not
okay we're in the Bitcoin chart so as I
was saying as long as we hold the 15 in
the four hour time frame we're gonna
favor higher prices 29 600 seems quite
uh interesting and even to be honest why
not this one over here above all these
highs that's a thirty thousand three
hundred we go to the Daily time frame
let's see what the daily time frame
tells us uh well you can see that this
zone is also liquidity pool
check this Zone okay this is another
liquidity pool
so why not all the way to 33 300.
I don't see why not we will need the
50ma to hold now in the daily time from
the 50ma has been holding a support so
well you can see how many tested one two
three four five six it has tested
support six times so it's proven it's
worth okay
now
this is only telling me that you know we
have quite a solid support here and
higher prices are likely
especially twenty nine thousand six
hundred and thirty thousand three
hundred bow
if we start to lose this 50ma the 15 in
the daily time frame then I've said this
many times we're gonna look at this Zone
that 25
000 Zone okay so that would be you know
something like this
yeah uh 25
250. that's the song that's the next
song if we lose the 50 I mean the daily
time frame
um sorry for speaking so fast today but
I'm running a bit late with this video I
want you to see it as soon as possible
okay so thank you so much guys for
watching and I'll see you soon